welcome my name is Samuel Nixon Jr
and Alum of the MIT Gospel Choir
did you know that black students at MIT
have traditionally
relied on faith and music
for Spiritual sustenance through the
academic and social pressures of Life at
the Institute
yeah
the MIT Gospel Choir is a half century
year old example
of this tradition and meaningful
reliance
and from his early information in 1971
by others this body of faithful students
has grown from the informal original
group of 10 undergraduates Who quote
unquote simply
enjoyed singing to each other
according to the then president and
co-director Ricardo Hall to a more
formal and amazing group of solstice in
all walks of life
choir members have been singing
traditional gospel hymns and spirituals
for around five decades in local
churches in the Christian Fellowship
services at the MIT Chapel and all
around the Boston Cambridge area and
Beyond
today a segment of the MIT Gospel Choir
alums from across the years a privilege
to present to you
few moments of joy and celebration of
some of the historic journey of this
Legacy choir
won't you pause with us now to remember
some of the singing fellowship and
exciting moments of sharing the gospel
and psalm in this special MIT Gospel
Choir presentation
it's our joy to share with you with each
musical noting chord
amidst the hustle and bustle of the
Season yeah we know we know
come relax and spend a few moments with
us as you hear the sweetness of some
Melodies of memorable moments and Voices
of Faith of expressed during our student
years yes
even around the corners of the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
welcome
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
very much
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
friends
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
greetings my name is Samuel Nixon Jr I
am an Alum of the MIT Gospel Choir
and I am thankful for as I look back on
and remember that time that I learned
about the choir around 1973 1974. when I
first came to MIT in 1973 somewhere
along the line as I was discovering my
way around campus and learning about
different organizations and perhaps
through some of the organizations like
the black Christian fellowship and
others I found out about the choir and
then went and asked how do you become a
member of it and they said all you have
to do is be willing to sing and lift up
your voice and follow the directions of
the director and uh that's the main
requirement is to be able to uh to to
participate and lift your voice together
so I said well in that case I will join
it was my first opportunity to be a part
of a gospel choir was that experience on
campus at MIT
and the choir uh for me meant the
opportunity to share in fellowship and
friendship with those that came to know
quite well over the years and to spend
some time not only singing with them in
the halls and Carters of MIT and Kresge
Auditorium and some of the other
locations but also around the Cambridge
and Boston area so for me it was a very
special opportunity in sharing the word
of the Lord through song and music in
different settings with people who also
shared in the faith there thankful as a
Christian that I was able to do that and
open up that door for a very definite
way of expressing the love and caring of
human uh spirit one to the other through
the MIT Gospel Choir the impact that the
choir had on the MIT Community I think
was very evident and smiles that people
had when they would pass by and said
that was very nice I enjoyed it I
appreciated it and needed to hear that
that made a difference in the spirit of
those who engage with the choir and that
was relevant in their faces as well as
their words of support not only there
but around the Austin Cambridge
Community has acquired that opportunity
to sing with other choirs and churches
and on special occasions and for
fundraising events and other things too
especially at Kresge Auditorium where we
invited other choirs to join us in
lifting up the songs of praise and Zion
in a special way
one of the things I remember a lot about
the choir is um
of the many is the time when we get
together for rehearsal sometime we would
just always have time to just fellowship
and and playfully engage one another
Soviet directors and some of the our
directors like there Ricardo Hall and
Lee Allen and some of our musicians Gary
Wilson uh Gerald Payne and others they
had the real Us in and saying okay it's
time to get down to business so we had
to focus on getting to the music but we
enjoyed it and had a good time so we
thank God for the blessing of the choir
and look forward to over these 50 plus
years that has continued to make a
difference in the lives of others it
being a difference in the ages to come
thank you
my name is Lee Allen and I served as one
of the pianists and directors of the MIT
Gospel Choir between 1973 and 1977.
so I have these three questions and I'll
do my best to give you some answers
first question what led you to
participate in the choir I was led to
participate by Ricardo Hall who found me
playing piano somewhere on campus in a
practice room or dorm room somewhere up
to that point I only knew Ricardo is
that enthusiastic guy at the cash
register at the tech Coupe so as I was
playing piano you came up put his hand
on my shoulder from behind and announced
that I was going to help him with the
choir
there's no discussion this is more like
him making an informational announcement
so second question what was most
meaningful about your experience in
participating in MIT Gospel Choir
the most meaningful result for me was
that it eventually got me back into
church because we would occasionally
play and perform at local churches I
think that little bit of nurturing
eventually revived my small girl of
faith I don't think that it was all that
evident during my MIT undergraduate
years but eventually it had an effect
the third question how would you say the
MIT Gospel Choir impacted the MIT and
wider Boston Cambridge communities
during your experience with the choir
I think that on campus we offered a
broadening of the MIT experience we were
one bit of evidence that you don't have
to choose between the things the tech or
the things of spirituality
off campus I think it ever so little
went towards humanizing the image of
those MIT people
they're supposed to wrap up an anecdote
to our favorite memory so I have one one
of my favorite memories is from our
first year Ricardo's on the piano we're
going through a song from start to
finish for the first time so this is
always an exciting moment well this time
it was so exciting for Ricardo that he
played this huge finale with giant
flourish and then he turned and yelled
cook number
so this is what he had to say to each
customer when they came to the register
at the coupe for a second everyone
including Ricardo was like what
and then everyone including Ricardo was
laughing because they understood it was
pretty funny but at the same time it was
a real bonding moment because he was
telling us that he was really happy
about things at that moment
Beyond normal words
foreign
[Music]
train is coming
don't need no ticket
you just get on board
all you need is faith
stay in the Diesels coming
no baggy
the Lord
People Get Ready
thank you
foreign
[Music]
there's no hiding place
better get ready for the train is gone
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
very much
[Music]
into your cause
[Applause]
[Music]
your holy man and Glory Glory
[Applause]
[Music]
anywhere
[Applause]
tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
until tomorrow
[Music]
[Applause]
time
[Music]
I'm ready
to go
it's time for me
lives tomorrow
[Music]
foreign
anyways
[Music]
shows
[Applause]
[Music]
see
you
[Music]
hi my name is Celia Berry Class of 1978
course 3.
when I arrived at MIT in 1974 there
weren't a whole lot of Black Folk and so
since I had been singing in the choir in
New York in my church I was more than
happy to join the MIT Gospel Choir
we not only minister to each other but
we form long lasting relationships and
we spiritually uplifted the MIT
community and the community in the
Boston area
one of my Fondest Memories was
sponsoring a gospel concert in Kresge
Auditorium with choirs from all over the
Boston area
I will always cherish and remember those
good times
growing up in the church I was always
active in the church choirs during my
high school years so I was really
looking forward to join the choir at MIT
I really enjoyed the fellowship
with my classmates the sharing of the
word and a Bible study
and I was always amazed by how our
director was able to write songs just
for the choir
As we sing and praise the Lord lift him
up his name
now regarding the community it was a
blessing to share the good news with the
MIT community and the surrounding area
when we had concerts on campus we were
able to have other Collegiate choirs
participate
my senior year we had an opportunity to
go on tour the MIT Gospel Choir on tour
and we visited and sang at Yale
University and we also visited New York
City and we performed at one of our high
school members High School in Mount
Vernon
an antidote I would share that was the
first time I drove in the snow
in New York on tour in the 15 passenger
van
being one of one of the few with the
driver's license but we made it and we
made it back safe but it was truly a
blessing and I had a wonderful time
hi my name is Shannon Martin and I used
to be a part of the MIT Gospel Choir
um I joined because I like to sing
gospel music and I wanted to get the
chance to meet and fellowship with other
students of color and just join together
with them to praise and worship God
and when I think about you know what the
choir meant to me I would say it it
meant that I had a place to go where
people could understand me more than
just on a surface level and it just gave
me that safe place that I needed to
express myself creatively and Also
spiritually
and I think the choir had an amazing
impact on the MIT Community
um it brought like a richness of
cultural tradition and I think it
allowed the light of
um a lot of people's shared musical
talent to be able to shine
um in terms of some of the memories I
have I remember our ebony Affair
um I was uh singing a Hallelujah
Salvation and Glory uh with two of my
closest friends and there was so much
talent in the room it just blew me away
and also the food was really good
let's have a warm welcome for the MIT
Gospel Choir
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
to my father's house
[Music]
it's gonna be nobody there yeah
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
let me know
[Music]
you're my father's house
[Applause]
if we're not true I would have told you
though
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
down
here
in my father's house
[Music]
I would have told you so
come on and go with me here
[Music]
[Applause]
the money
[Music]
[Applause]
you come home
[Music]
[Applause]
away
and Ransom captives
[Music]
[Applause]
rejoice
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for taking the time to share
in this inaugural special presentation
by the MIT Gospel Choir alums we hope
that you found it enriching encouraging
and even exciting as we've revealed just
a glimpse of the history of over a half
a century that this organization has
been offering songs of Hope and help and
healing to a hurting world
the MIT Gospel Choir is a witness of
what has been a significant part of our
life-changing experiences while engaged
in our academic studies at MIT
as you've just heard and experienced and
the music testimonials and songs of just
a few of the alums in our group
you can tell that this organization has
been a blessing to many not just those
in the MIT Community but also across the
Greater Boston Cambridge area and even
the eastern coast of the United States
we are grateful to have made a
difference in the lives of the people
whom we've touched through song and
witness and our service to our community
and we'd like to give thanks to those
who have taken the time such as yourself
to hear our voices speak to the value of
the relationships and the fellowship
that we've experienced in our faith
Journeys
many have passed our way and still have
very fond memories of the bonds and
lifelong relationships that were
fostered through the MIT Gospel Choir as
it grew and developed over the years
there is much more to come as we look
forward to presenting more of the joyful
and revealing ways that the MIT Gospel
Choir has impacted the communities of
MIT Boston and Cambridge and the East
Coast
stay tuned for our 2023 series of
presentations that will be offered
through the activities of the black
alumni of MIT also known as bambit and
the MIT Alumni Association
it's an exciting time for a reunion for
our choir and we invite you to be a
special part of it
if you would like more information you
can contact May white Wesson at
maywesson AOL.com that's spelled
m-a-e-w-e-s-s-o-n aol.com or you can
also contact Samuel Nixon Jr at s
nixonj2 at AOL.com that's spelled
s-n-i-x-o-n-j the number two at AOL.com
we will also be releasing announcements
through the bammit and MIT alumni
networks over the course of 2023. this
has been a production of the MIT Gospel
Choir alums
foreign
[Music]
don't need no tickets
all you need is faith
to hear the Diesels coming